qué fracción de este círculo está
coloreada de rojo
bueno pues vamos a ver este círculo está
dividido en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 partes de
las cuales 7 están coloreadas de rojo
entonces podemos decir que 7 de 8 partes
están coloreadas de rojo aunque bueno
esta no es la forma que utilizamos
generalmente cuando estamos escribiendo
fracciones generalmente nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a escribir 7 entre 8 y
aquí nos referimos a que 7 partes están
coloreadas de rojo así es que bueno pues
vamos a poner por aquí mejor al 7 en
color rojo
7 de 8 partes del círculo están
coloreadas de rojo están coloreadas de
rojo
pero bueno cuando estamos escribiendo
esto en la computadora no hay forma en
la que nosotros podamos poner 7 entre 8
y entonces lo que hacemos es escribirlo
de esta forma 7 entre 8 6 7 de 8 partes
están coloreadas de rojo bueno vamos a
checar nuestra respuesta comprobar
respuesta correcto siguiente pregunta
ahora vamos con el siguiente ejercicio
qué fracción de la barra está coloreada
de rojo bueno pues la barra tiene 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 secciones de las cuales 8
están coloreadas de rojo entonces
podemos decir que 8 novenos están
coloreados de rojo ahora vamos a
comprobar la respuesta y vamos al
siguiente ejercicio qué fracción de este
círculo está coloreado de rojo bueno
pues aquí tenemos uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve partes iguales de este círculo
bueno pero con también cuántos pedazos
hay a ver vamos a contarlos otra vez 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 partes iguales de las
cuales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 están coloreadas de
rojo entonces vamos a poner por aquí
siete sobre 9 7 novenos y vamos a
comprobar la respuesta